if you don't know I am playing a match
against Ben Feingold it's me the fourth
so I think something about Star Wars
there are a few images circulating
Twitter and I think some kind of thing
on chess calm but yeah this should be
interesting
never play the full match against Bend
before only play them a few times think
in arena Kings maybe a few times on his
stream - I prepared a lot for my my
other matches in this this I am NOT a GM
now I'm playing a GM I don't prepare as
much but there is there's a sponsor
sponsoring a prize fund for this so the
the winner will get $600 a second place
gets $400 so there is some incentive to
play for rich-rich five six ten cents a
thousand bits to the oh I'll try my best
yeah go usually the saying is go band
that go me thank you flow though for
subbing too old too slow but which one
of us maybe both of us I don't know pay
say to me thanks for something yeah
thanks so much okay London time I'm not
gonna yeah let's let's hide the chat
this monitor and I'm this monitor okay
no more looking at the chats
he's gonna play some Queen oh he plays a
smooth let's a move so he's trying to
confuse me I'll play Knight of three
let's see 392 I'm basically waiting for
d6 and then I'll play Bishop c4 I'll
still play Bishop c4 bishops actually
decent here d5 I just move back
um probably to me first yeah this is
gonna feel a lot different compared to
my my other matches because I wasn't
streaming other matches so I'll have to
try and play seriously but also offer
commentary so basically kind of what I
usually do
it's titled Tuesday style let's play
rookie 1 1 so one of the main plans is
black wants to play e5 my plan is just
to be solid
don't want to plunder anything play for
some 85 ideas some 22 ideas we need to
maybe not the best move actually there's
a trap we need to rikiei I can take King
takes on the 95-96 that could be kind of
cool actually if he plays rook e8 right
now it falls into it so a4 was kind of a
nice waiting move plays d5 ok in d5 a
move so I think it makes sense to put
the bishop on d3 to ensure that he can't
just plant a knight on e4 h sure he was
useful to me tonight h5 with Bishop each
two so he plays rook e8 so now there's
no Bishop f7 which is kind of sad for
that slice let's play Knight 95 slight
time advantage nothing too special
should take with Bishop if we're still
control he might try and just trade
everything Daisy 6 like Queen e2 idea
Bishop a6 maybe some a5 just wanna
massage his his Queen side pawns
okay here probably have to take is he
gonna play off six you might play off
six here but f6 is probably just
terrible
not sure who's gonna be the first one in
this match to play off six please Queen
f6 okay so I have Bishop Bishop e5 a5
looks really nice
Corinne f6 is kind of a sign that he
does want to play e5 but if I'm just
drops a pawn
so let's play let's play a5 and there's
no increment so that's another thing to
adjust to if they get used to just dirty
flagging which I shouldn't feel too bad
about if it comes down to it thanks for
subbing so are you play a six I probably
want to leave the tension the question
is how to actually make some improvement
there's visual a6 here it seems
counterintuitive there's a Bishop e5
actually there should be five looks
looks decent because I want to just take
and then plant the knight on e5 and then
have a good night versus bad digit
like really wants to come to d6o Bishop
Bishop c6 interesting leave some tension
what some yeah let's just chill
please rook b8 Oh what to do I can take
if I take he kind of has to take with a
pawn let's do that and like rook a7
trying to infiltrate okay one coming
some potential like this minority attack
the single pawn uh we could end up
trading everything it's not exactly what
I want Brooks he's seven and actually
it's interesting so takes takes work
eight rooks he's seven the rook looks
dumb ones he sudden but it might be okay
there's Rick a 191 this should a eight
that's probably not good yeah let's take
a mission b5 because those bishop is
still stuck again the knight really
wants to come to d6 but it's far away
from d6
hmm
so here I can I can take and continue to
massage the Queen side there's ninety
five right away ninety-five 24 there's
also Queen a6 which looks appealing it's
play 95 let's focus on the King side
according a for Queen f3 up six then
whole okay he'll be the first one to
play f6 probably
hopefully it won't come with a BAM
there's no G for ideas - followed by
Queen e5 its queenie southern 94 why not
thanks for something okay
I mean it's it's a positional saying
okay let's do this check and then Queen
beings so I'm attacking the pond if you
wants to defend the Pawnee on the bishop
there's queen bee Saturn but then Queen
here
oh there's Bishop there too and decent
move hmm not seeing the knockout play 93
moving a little bit too slowly
got one maneuver in line I guess 2 F 3 F
6 was a good move like night of three
and then push the Jeep on maybe some
Nike for ideas - somebody's stuck on the
the queenside which is why he's taking
Titan because there's no clear path to
progress for black so I just have to
play quickly g4 might come that's a move
okay let's get the night here Alex kind
of extending I don't know if it's
overextending it is extending okay wait
he just allowed this move Queen g8 I
forgot about it but that's okay because
Queen G it's gonna strike a punch uh
yeah like Queen g8 I 26 now and then 95
Khan's ooh what does this move he just
once again made it or he's yeah he's
going in what is this
see the meat Chuck what is this
he's doing great things play the smooth
I'm still baffled I just have to bring
my queen back maybe 5c4 quindi one
should be made for Queenie one okay how
does a weird game there is a moment
almost f3 could have been made there
there's one idea wow what a game that
was a weird game so and his kiss king
power like almost worked kind of if that
game act if that game is like a sign for
how the match is about to go it's gonna
be a crazy match alright let's play
something try and be solid thanks for
the bits nosh something something um
let's play e6 yeah I was very flustering
it's still slightly shaking now a GN
thanks for the bits alright so I'm
playing my pet line a 6 and 97
mmm Queens like castles interesting so I
think I'll go for like b5 Bishop e7 90
for the right moment I want to play c5
and think you Cho Cho Cho Dan for the
bits as well
please h3 yeah the bishop is decent here
helps control efore wait what
okay that was a mouse slip I forgot
there there's no way to disable click
click I have to be really careful when I
draw her was Bishop c6 it probably just
really confused him also I'm probably
losing a pawn here
I'm just losing upon I was yeah I was
really unfortunate it's not the end of
the world I'm just gonna be down the
pawn yeah h7 falls I have two bishops to
make the best of it um Queen e7 or Queen
d6 and Queen g6 is probably know like I
still want to play c5
in queenie southern still conflicting it
probably doesn't matter too much like
windy six yeah this is the position I'm
really missing my H pong oh there's
before there's c4 or there c5
immediately let's see if I might
actually work because takes takes we
flip on gets h6 I'll play in g6
terrifying though okay so there is
before there's rook c8 actually Brooksie
it could be very nice but it hangs of
hangs a thing yeah Bishop control CAS so
maybe maybe g6 here geez looks looks so
weakened but let's imagine g6 Bishop d3
rook c8 he does have g5 I'm actually
realizing I couldn't sack the exchange
rooks rook c8 Bishop takes c8
rook takes c8 it doesn't quite work
though or it doesn't maybe your exceed
immediately rook c8 takes takes I'm
throwing some g5 move but the whole
planets to get in before spending way
too much time as well let's play rook c8
let me just make him think so move that
I I initially wanted to play before
seeing the bishop so he plays g5 that's
probably a strong move like if I take I
just get destroyed
takes takes actually yeah I just get
destroyed let's play this thanks for
solving see rabbit Arab burry I am just
glancing at these names solve probably
guarantee mispronounced alone okay so
I'm down the exchange but there's
there's two to big things on the C file
so plans to take and play d4 I guess
there's 94 this should be okay so before
what's this plan 94 queenie 5 because
there's f4 there oh it's getting weird
again if i could just kind of just take
the knight takes takes takes another's
rook there's 57 in the end mmm almost
works and if i like we need 5 f4 like we
not 5 moving way too slowly
so there's definitely definitely chances
here to come back yeah just going out
five let's take so I have two bishops
always play off six yeah I'll play 85
defend defend some more it's not
pleasant that was really not pleasant my
bishops are just so powerless is a
question like can might actually break
through though Queen c7 I trade Queen
takes a six they'll have some chat
I just want to push the upon problem as
I might be stuck soon what's my next
move
that's a good move I have to take ya
there's no tricks here okay I resigned
yeah the position was difficult after
this is Bishop c6 moved but I tried to
fight I spent way too much time though
um yeah have to adjust Ultima II for mix
it up so it's one-to-one you place
Carroll Khan expecting a 5 yeah that's
all he played this against coast in yoke
and some probably some arena king
there's something so just proud playing
a solid ROTC mindset on the Queen on c2
and b5 probably a 3za approach trysting
zoom g3 moon have to be careful with
thumb as a c5 idea I could take and
maybe I will take you one connect four
on the queenside congratulations
no it's be solid b3
if I ever see five now I have night
sanity five plays Bishop c5 makes me
want to play this move because usually
block wants to play g6 but it's a bit
weakening to the dark squares
let's take with her
a few ideas here I mean not a five of
course there's just a concept of
controlling the d-file your work t3
Queen d2 maybe I'll do that how do you
want to play g3 to prevent some metaphor
move I'm probably g3 here
it looks really wrong I'm allowing 94
I'll play quitting d2 and then my goal
is to playing out of five or nine three
and again if c5i I should have 95
probably one of the throwing Bishop g2
h6 confuses me
maybe he was scared of Queen g5 so b5 b5
invites c5 which is a move there's
something like that v idea to go for a
night of 5 yeah really questioning the
night it plays before before it probably
makes it fun of sense cuz c5 coming
let's try this
I'm time for f3 I could take and then
playoff 3 I'll play let's do this first
then f3 actually f3 is probably not
necessary actually maybe it is and
that's kind of a sad f3 yes yeah doc has
a better structure but I have a good
night always have to look on the bright
side down about a minute Wow so slow ok
let's play a g4 idea g5
and you have more pawns on the Kings
side let's keep pushing g6 I always have
this move
that's gonna be far enough - if g6 I'm
not sure if I want to play 96 or not I'm
also playing a g6 let's play this idea
f4 because e4 will be defended also
hitting this
now the platform could be very nice the
queenside is kind of held together time
is balancing out which is very nice
these rook a to what brocade to I take
what I guess he's going for a positional
play that's created was very creative
um I can't spend too much time I
probably just have to take and then
punish him
there's Bishop or there's Queen e7 Queen
e7 looks really nice and Bishop c8 I
think I can just take Bishop h3 and then
like rook 3d to I mean the Knight wants
to come to a4 which is kind of
terrifying there's also this move to
throw in actually f4 could be very nice
as Bishop c8 f for I attacked the queen
of Queens eggs f4 there's rook F 1 and F
7 is falling an end
yeah he played this with idea that
midnight comes to f4 wow it's still
coming to f4 so I think I want to throw
in f4 and then just win the bishop
I'll be threatening regatta lon okay be
this mmm sure it's tricky
work fYI get mean okay let's be careful
how they're gonna have to sack that
Queen takes g550 - that's it's annoying
position so when I teach theory I think
I can play King h2 there meanwhile I'd
probably do want to take even like this
move I probably wrote got to is a threat
because it's night okay so he plays that
let's play clear this I'm up a whole rug
and up on time now he wants her pets
probably not going to happen at six BAM
use a lot of funds to try okay
pawns were slightly scary Wow okay so
that's that's two for me
White has won every single game that's a
fun game I felt yeah I felt like
momentum was going his way
let's play something different opening
find names oh you can see 285 it's all
expected thanks tog II jinx now the GM
for the bits folks well you play as
Bishop H for he usually plays Bishop
takes f6 I mean I did like a little bit
of preparation for him so I though I
know something about this line who but I
don't know this move that's a new move I
assumed is a v6
move is like III know 3 etc mainly etc
but ok the idea is to take out a pawn
even like um lady sobbing rook c8 while
please II for I mean this is by far the
sharpest move g5 is very tempting and e4
is very thematic I'm wondering if I can
just take on on c3 like takes on c3 if
Queen takes c3 Knight takes e4 and if
pawn takes c3 then like g5 I mean like
to throw in this move but then takes
it's ok let's yeah let's take on c3
thanks for solving any 10 1994 oh wow so
he takes there so I'm temporarily up a
piece but I'm gonna lose a piece back
have Bishop e5 may be confusing position
what's going on here I could just be
much worse Bishop g4 actually I'm 54 I
guess he plays off 3
going on visualg for f3 I can just take
on B to move back these pawns are so
strong it's a problem if I take on d5
maybe take fun ok takes on d5 actually
looking at takes on on d5 Queen takes c3
Knight e4 takes and then takes
Prabhas our c4 in the end so it takes
takes money for takes takes takes takes
c4 life's not fair takes say queen takes
any other move there's g5 still g5 looks
so weakening oh but g5 Bishop g3 94 okay
let's go for vision g4 not super fond of
this line because the pawns are
be hard to remove but maybe okay maybe
the c-pawn will be weak and some some
cases a given f3 Bishop e5 takes in the
97 yeah I probably want to keep the
darks for addition you can this is
somewhat practical so I'm I'm down the
pawn but I have all the minor pieces
developed White's King site isn't
developed so things tell you for the
bits I won't be really reading messages
but thanks for the bits that's a good
move probably I have I have a g5 mm-hmm
I for Roxy ain't I just want to win this
pawn it could be difficult okay if c6
you see 695 I'll before so let's yeah
let's destroy the pawn chain he's gonna
play a three takes takes I could sack
apiece let's do it
I'm low on time I just want to I want to
win quickly or lose quickly but there's
some I mean at least it's easy to play
like the ideas are very simple just
either made on a one or take on c5 so I
can take on c5 first Queen e2 I'm 22 I
could play that I can take on f6
something to fight for b5 is a threat
this
also a threat so defendant Bishop
throw-in this move
being ultra aggressive
how you ate but it's difficult it's not
the move I want to play there try this
and to stop rook see one I used to play
rook c3 next in the vent of rookie for
that's a good move though
well Bishop e5 is would be really nice
but the night controls e5 can now be
should be 5
actively it's probably just really bad
but I'm just little flagging to night
spinned okay I'm threatening to win the
pawn 22 is simple before you can take on
off seven let's try this I think it's
still complicated
yeah I was in our sleep
oh I tried
got him below 10 seconds was interesting
fights again time though unfortunate
mile slip at the end too because there
is still still definitely some fight
there
thank you for again expecting Sicilian
French play this line b6 okay um yeah
I've actually don't know what what to
expect here he's gonna play d5 just I
stopped him try and saw them the idea
taken Queenie 7 oh it's probably just
bad though girls check there's some tilt
from the last game yeah this
is probably just a dubious opening
thanks for the bits whoever that was
yeah like pieces don't make sense here
before is a cool move
they're chic we need to we need to is
playable please King f8 wow so we're
both we both kind of have done a dumb
setup like this is a game you would see
maybe played between two players rated
like 700 it's like the bishop on d3 the
knight here the bishop blocked by its
pawns block my cast lighting I'm not
castling
or just both playing dumb chess but it's
still it's interesting at least my
pieces are about to make sense okay so
there's a for ideas but should be okay
there's this idea mmm so you want to do
9f to
completely like night a for late work
f1a for is kind of a cool move
unleashing the bishop attacking this
trying to call box bluff on this sort of
threats so I assume just King f1 no
threats h3
okay time is decent this game thanks for
the bits hard Krishnan over the board
chess at least in u.s. I guess I was
referring to us reigning each three
takes takes yeah looks interesting
because each file opens now hmm there's
a lot of fun options there's a Knight g5
is Queenie five especially XD Saturn
let's go for a night
five like these these pieces are all
like so well coordinated we're just
trying to find the knockout blow
like if h6 sort of Bishop g6 it's kind
of cool because H pawns pins also am
threatening probably and I takes HS a
turn also rookie so all the piece like
all of whites pieces can come into play
yeah the opening fell it's so terrible
that this is beginning to make sense
also there's a g6 here is a really cool
move I mean it feels like a showboating
move but why not Bishop g6 you mean the
pawns pin this one's pain this plant
side down to e6 and I've sevens hard to
defend a7 is also stuck to covering e6
there are probably a lot of good moves
there 27 is expected in 27 the very
least I went upon on a 7
have to be careful though when seven
takes takes so I like the slide takes
and then I takes off seven assuming
Bishop takes rook to you I can take on
h7 of the rook
take the night's and then like rookie
one yeah the tag is still very much
raging
so there's a cool threat of 9h six do
you want to take the pawn first that's
actually a little bit I should have
taken with the C pawn
there's g5 here but Bishop c4 and vision
a6 if I take oh there's some meat
threats
so take stakes
this is good in an age six threatening
meets also finding the road yeah so I
saw this I don't think it hurts me you
force covered it's really hard to defend
this [ __ ] be seven but then I take and
then take on you seven let's not pre
move that I forgot takes the rook
defends that would be a really fat cream
but okay if takes I I'm a Donny eight
yeah how does how does black started
okay he plays on like this so let's uh
let's take here interesting put this
back and rookie seven coming or even
will play King H one first and then
vision g6 and now mate is coming or not
okay I'll do this and win the bishop
okay loveless and g3 was a nice resource
okay um I think one more game of
5-minute chests now the GM thanks for
the bits and I'd see anything's for the
bits yeah that was a cool game like this
Bishop g6 move okay oh let's go back to
this opening thanks Mike c8 for the bits
yeah we'll just repeat the same opening
and this time trying to avoid now
slipping okay so he plays rook t1 with
rook t1 I think the best moves to take
and still go for this thanks for subbing
I'll be rough please
- so he's trying to discourage c-5 so
play see if I could play rook c8 first
that's a decent move and thanks Seth
Babbage from the bits - so before is a
move what side you had before he wants
to play e5 I think that's okay so maybe
throw in h6 to this first I just want to
breathe before is kind of a threat so
you put the work on do you want to make
it more difficult for me to play c5 or
to prepare d5 ok d5 I could consider
taking I assume the idea z5i takes e5
there's night somewhere 98 is kind of
sad you can also just take here I'm not
to find out I guess 98 I mean up
appalling these pawns will hopefully be
strong I'm not getting needed yet
tonight is really sad against the spawn
though we can't really move forward
knife at five is coming then is probably
getting so much pleasure from getting to
playing out of five okay let's play c5
go for d4 like that let alone can't hurt
me
they're clean
now Queen d5 loses everything what to do
rook c7 that's not pleasant though the
one benefit of this night it does defend
g7 so kind of a defender thanks for
subbing Lars Lars one place f4 I mean
the see if c4 works I do want to play it
it doesn't
to work though 27 when Bishop g4 not
sure here because this Queen eight move
kind of fancy if I play see ya see four
just doesn't work
rook d7 maybe that losses upon Queen D
for me between g5 I was going to Bishop
f3 but Bishop f3 I can be greedy
go after the pawn it's so greedy though
but upon the pond oh he takes on and he
takes on e7 takes on c5 have to go for
it this couldn't like just liquidate
into some equal ending if we turn on he
stopped and he wins he five we trade on
f3 I play Queen C 4 Oh Queen takes d5
it's another move I'm just missed so
there is rooks he 7 was Knight is so bad
though let's
yeah let's try this I'll have the c-4
square for a rook has to take with [ __ ]
I'm in b2 then Roxy for coming
so maybe I'm winning be too regardless
there's some Queen d5 move though 25 I
take on b2
okay so night once
back into play I mean c3 rook c3 be
Queen c3 oh that was such a bad move
because rook t3 that's such a bad move
okay I'll still try and fight I haven't
I have a dumb line on eight and I'm less
than two minutes took time there maybe
he's scared I'm an outside passer that's
a good move though BG 697 c6 is gonna
come probably for f5
have to pray
so there's one of six 9f5 work takes off
five takes off 520 x86 it looks like I'm
getting made in but then Queenie one
meets that's someone hope there's queen
of a two and everything loses again
Queen takes like six I I'm eight please
do it I said please play this move god
I'm just gonna meet a DA likes winning
every game well okay so I think we take
a break right we take a break
five-minute pre off game at least I can
chill now for a little bit yeah so the
format is six games of five minute yeah
okay I actually don't know it's some
kind of mug there there's some symbol I
don't know what stands for this is gonna
be close three to three
why does four games away from adopting
black
what'd I do wrong anything Volusia look
nice I think sliced Samir yeah we're
tied
we are tied yeah it's a lot of chatter
to keep up with I'll try and address the
relevant questions yeah it's not a
psychedelic drink it's just uh it's a
gold label it's a rebel I have to
improve my my brain capacity so he
played a next same all be white probably
so he he played French caro-kann and um
I played London one game I kind of like
the position I got from London so I
might repeat that and this may be all I
don't know I repeat sometimes oh maybe
I'll play like I'll play some crazy
openings have to see xlab yeah thanks
thanks disaster cuz the X n bits I
actually don't know who the sponsor is
but some someone is putting up the prize
fund I think one of someone been notes
but whoever whoever's putting up the
prize fund really appreciate it
also yeah thanks to everyone who's
cheering and and southern and just being
here and witnessing some some kind of
history so yeah so there's gonna be
eight games of three minutes so will be
much more fast-paced there really
haven't been I need dirty flags all the
games are coming down to the the
position the exception that maybe the
first game
um that first game was a messy time
scannable but with three minutes
undoubtedly time is going to be more
relevant well it's just explained just
explained it's now a son gifted by
Admiral thanks so much
it Wardle I have not had a chance to
check there were some behinds I prepared
that involve early at least early f6 but
he's not going into them sadly so I'll
see
hey it's Libra human cubicle artists
with nine point nine nine dollars thanks
so much
hopefully that's a lucky number for me
as well yeah let's uh VIP chess explains
very very famous chess youtuber has a
lot of courses now I think untestable
it's a steel gear also played in the I
am not a GM all I can't I can't add a
VIP because I have too many VIPs oh I'm
so sorry
well you'll you'll be a VIP and in our
hearts I guess anyway yeah I guess I'll
I'll wait for the challenge or a lemme
text Ben just let me know when the next
go Eric yeah that's me
I feel like as a match goes on the
openings are probably gonna get more and
more dubious along with just the general
nature of the chests in whites really
been performing well I really like the
position though kind of around here I
was feeling comfortable and then I just
didn't know what to do
got to improve my night maybe rook t7 c5
was loose this was just a bad idea okay
Ben's ready let's play another game oh
how I challenged him okay I'll be
closing down the chest and three minutes
three minutes
thanks for the bits Tonya taki okay
focus cent going back to d4 let's see if
he wants to repeat ooh he's playing a
new opening fish about five okay let's
play this line like this again Speights
and got a good position idea yeah idea
g4 h for half three let's go f3 BAM h4
and now yeah this is supposed to be very
nice h5 I'll take on g6 probably play g5
vision d6
these are really the only two moves I
think well it's to do he might like go
crazy and suck something so let's take
[Music]
kind of like this maybe see fun oc3
solid an idea Queen c2 okay he'll have
neither fate that's a pleasant position
please g v g5 makes sense so i take i
could take all the times and then it
gets a bit weird inclined to just leave
the tension like i have the bishop pair
i have healthier pawn structure place c5
so this is nice so i'm preparing this
and if 9f8 thought I could take of the
pin interesting if he wants to play king
g8 and that looks really bad for for
black but maybe it's playable
I'm just go for this so there's Bishop
this is Bishop f7 move which could just
be winning neither faith it gets a bit
messy I think it's it's worth going for
now there's some idea like just bring
the rook to each one and mate yeah like
probably queenside castling actually the
king should be safe there g6 I can take
it yeah so I want a pawn in the process
really nice still attacking position
he's trying to attack me have some like
let's try this ideas the playoff for
I could take first Wow
I forgot we switched the three minute I
don't have time I just have to play
quickly
mmm Bishop takes you three unmanned to
take there I should look like
be one sooner should have followed the
been Feingold rule here I can take 94
coming I don't know what he's thinking
oh you thinking about taking those that
move was this know what he just did
there I was weird
he accidentally cream of something he
hasn't been resigning being used tilting
though or raging
that's a nice mates all right
white white continues to win all the
games Wow
some yeah let's see what he plays
against Budapest
thanks for the bet it's not a GM he's
playing this line he probably knows what
he's doing - Queen B ok Queen b3 is a
new moon at least for me if I make sense
if eight I think a for how this is
already new position for me
I mean Bishop c5 is also interesting but
let's maintain the pin
could take counter yadda
let's take once ooh fancy
he likes the Castle queenside for some
reason the every game he's white he's
casting queenside except the previous
game his whites so this is a nice kind
of positional structure but yeah the
game might get tactical maybe f6 here
BAM f6 controlling everything defending
the pawn to d6 discouraging c5 man it
feels like I'm playing checkers now and
he's playing chess there should be seven
what's natural I don't know what to do I
don't know what my plan is maybe look
here I'm decent square for the rock and
I run with the king
really Wow that's a move yeah King da
was terrible so let's have to take have
to play this I should see these things
d7
this is
uncomfortable
what to do like the Queen Queen is very
hard to remove bg5 first
you have
this queen aids coming well played
I'm gonna fight on cuz why not there's
very little hope though I was a good
move Bishop e5 would be mate
me six okay three ideas f3 BAM what to
do I'm just completely suck I want to
fork the rooks
jeetu is hard to stop actually that was
a good move though yeah there's no
there's nothing good gain white wins
again Wow
so it's four to four why he has won all
eight games that's insane
so we're playing what we're playing six
more let's play this again see five
let's take it I just want to be quick
with time
this would be three here
- it's not so impressive probably just
going to get some position
yeah like takes not a three can complain
with this kind of some kind of Sicilian
position they three useful move
ninety-four fancy so 9h for is always an
idea then queen 323 94 let's try this
okay I want to get any nine-to-five
eventually I also want to play us three
always play off three
you
ideas gonna be nine five I want to play
g4 but f3 is a bit weak maybe I
shouldn't have played out three so much
regrets but still play a little let's
play that's named
now g4
I just want to get rid of that night and
then okay knife f5 let's go
losing b2 with an H for this is 96
d5 could be strong at some point yeah
h4
good move but okay I can take now he
punished my every move that's so sad
try something like this so seven is a
bit of a targets those nine on a three
is so strong now
that's unfortunate okay not much time
either Bishop III was terrible Wow
everything's falling apart that's
probably all because I play off three -
life's not fair there's no still many
possibilities in game yeah so white lost
a game so White's not getting adopted
maybe the the trend will have to reverse
those tough let's go back to an Enzo
every game it feels like my time is on
it's a little bit struggling so now he
goes for this line there's about five I
think is typical
why not look yet so very
kind of simple positional game like a
six makes sense he's gonna want to go
from minority attack I think the plan
here is to bring the Knights to to c4
so I could take and play if I play
nicely for immediately
what makes you poor right away yeah so
my plan structure is a little bit less
desirable but I have a good night
play rugby eights possibly for
three a five to start with alright let's
yeah let's start of this before it won't
threaten anything you play you got a
five here so the ideas to play rook
before and I'm probably a v8 very
symmetrical pawn structure now the Queen
d7
these outposts probably just equal
time will be relevant in 92 you play
Queen g3 he wants to play 96 but 92
attacks us for a can prepare Zeus
I mean not exactly what I want
look see 7:00 tomorrow so I could take
93 and then when he was pawn I should
have an outside passer bring the King
into I just want to trade nights a lot
of night of five at thinking king d5
Wow of clothes I won my first game with
black let's go it's five five Wow
the game if we play four more games of
this plate for again and the absolute no
tape can play off for thanks for the
bits not a Gian seems to be cheering
every time I win thanks for that okay so
Grand Prix
oh you please a four that's probably
good move away nine eight four here and
see for liking each one
and we'll play some kind of French
structure I guess and Bishop f5 Queen f2
will bring the knight here actually
there's probably more more important
things to worry about like this some I
do you like c5 idea b3 bishop a3
complain with the position this pawn is
as kind of a target bishop before could
be coming between g2 I'm trying to hold
things together
I'll bring the knight back try and force
the trades well I honestly forgot about
that move shouldn't be too bad we could
just trade everything and my structure
staying the way it is if I get the
chance I would like to take on before
and don't know if it works here though
it probably doesn't c5
that's a good move
I take em I take this way some rook t1
moon
position is ya under so much pressure
here
take six weeks training us define will
be week well I just got forts or no I
didn't that's not great though I lost
upon okay I'm trying to fight I'm down
on time though too
trying to make a pass pawn succeeded to
it takes I have a cough one
Black's finding himself in trouble kinda
might be a draw
yeah it's a draw Wow
Oh the weird game I was a really weird
game I felt like maybe I could have won
but I was also losing that game too so
can't complain I was down a ton of time
as well thanks for the bits nice eh
let's go back to the slime it was
playing one of the main lines 95 so
early 95 is playable
like when he
95 the at some point I do want to play
off six let me start with c5 here c5 b5
was actually surprisingly strong those
d5s week hmm if I play 95 doesn't seem
to work there should be sixes there
should be six is actually looking
playable as if a 5 digit g7 and the
Knights a bit more loose very delicate
positioned over this qualm
in one more move okay one more move feel
like what could have done something
better they're not sure now this is good
this game is gonna be a fight
c4 c4 makes sense I think and then I
can't play b5 yet it works e8 at some
point B 5
maybe 94 to f6 incoming not yet and yeah
so takes I
Bishop e5 I went back upon okay
howdy 5uu
have this move it's a battle against
this pawn East six is so weak maybe I
shouldn't have played off six hey rook
d7 it's interesting this pawns loose
both are white spawns are a bit
overextended this pawn is also extended
quite far
eighty-six
I'll bring a lot of trades
take sticks
that's not good
oh that's sad that's very sad
well played
houses yeah that was a good fight and
game was was actually very complex I
probably went wrong somewhere even then
the King pawn ending 94 again
wait he just dropped upon what is this
you just dropped upon for nothing
and so tilted multiplied Bishop d2 there
okay well not the end of the world
still a fight tagging this pawn Queens I
castling I went up seven hmm it's a
slight surprise okay so we need both
dropped pawns
I'm fine with training to be a little
bit careful go also tuck the King away
yeah this isn't the prettiest setup this
looks so disgusting
this piece configuration but greens are
off the boards so the time is less
relevant unite here f3 and the e2 I
don't think I want to play off three
immediately only 92 first f3 should come
soon though those 93 work f2
some obstacle or Bishop situation
BAM moon ith okay Knights fives now not
a move King D 293 good move
let me take envision t1 its passive
probably is just passive specially for
first let's play bridge before it's
interesting strategic battle where yeah
it's very imbalanced b2 is gonna be
under pressure
I'll start with
put the work on e - don't think there's
tactics with taking on c3h ones always
guarded the night really wants to be on
e4
so 90 for anyone else to do there's work
see two extra safe move it was a smooth
let's play this move attack the pawn no
94 control d5
as very nice compositional setup that
was terrible move such a low quality
time scramble okay Wow Wow what was that
I was a weird yeah I was weird the match
is still tied how many games do we play
that was 13 we play one more game right
what a game thanks for the bits not a G
mm-hmm one more game let's play we've
passed again
I'll just let's start with this and then
I'll take yeah I played this against
Lavina it's a reasonable line six first
c4 is kind of hanging I don't think I
wanted to take it earlier the kinglet in
the center
a bit annoying considering a six here
there's not too many options there's
rook here at the p8 Asics kind of sacks
upon when upon back she let's play a six
probably not too bad at flights gives
away the light squared Bishop so takes
takes takes and then Queen takes a two
have to be careful with this click click
is yeah the Queen was selected okay
now takes on a two takes one c7 - me -
what's good for it and the dream is
takes and then fork or the dream is to
make a queen take with pond yeah
interesting endgame I don't to get mated
I was a good move rook f8 or Queen h5
like when h5 rook b8 d 87 this is
slightly terrifying
where's uh I just want to simplify let's
try this it's looking at rook d7 queen
of five doesn't seem to work though
mm and it's a very difficult position
five and just doesn't work and taking
place six doesn't work either didn't see
what to do there
for some like miracle perpetual
also see doing here okay okay no I'm
just gonna need it wow that's so sad
so one more right can I do math or is
that it I can't do math that's it right
break time I think it's a brain yeah so
ten games of one minute to decide this
madness wow that was a tough end game
yeah like I want to
I wanted to play Queen here it's not a
lot of time searching for solutions
after kingi to but it's just losing
because the back ring Brian I mean it's
very close I think neither of us have
been leading for for more than a point
like one point has been the biggest
margin so hopefully I'm due to win the
next game
yeah bullets should be injured
I'm not sure I mean I feels like I've
been faster than him and he's like time
scramble games I just have to get in the
minds of the bullets it's it's really
hard actually to transition from blitz
to bullets so he plays mostly random
stuff well he usually plays against
players much lower rated right we ease
been playing pretty consistent openings
I've been liking the positions I'm
getting with whites even like the
openings with black are ok but all the
games are decided just later on so
openings are not not too relevant well
Ben is really quiet and serious
interesting f6 doesn't yeah so f6 I
wanted to play in this position it
doesn't work cuz rook here and then
there's a mate threat and if I mean I
could try this but then just let's see
pong rules I'm tied down to everything
Queen's tied down to this and this and
the rook can't really activate so I
think it's just losing here is he
I mean he's leading the match he doesn't
really have a a great reason to be so
tilted but we'll see yeah I don't flag
is really good advice and bullets I know
he's like he has a lot of experience
making multiple premiums but even with
that like this this previous game we
played before this one kind of get the
sense that he's more prone to blundering
when getting these uh he's having the
pre moves was Rosen been student I think
everyone is has been student in some
regarding anyone who's watched a
Feingold video or stream is as a student
right even if you're learning like dumb
jokes it's still you're still learning
the answer is always frogs yeah so yeah
it's just about I think my previous
match against Davina I was just nervous
and I'm not affected me poorly in the
bullets here I just have to relax and
get ready to play really quickly if I'm
white next game probably be playing
actually I don't want to want to reveal
anything cuz there's there's probably
there's probably been Feingold
supporters watching right now but I'll
probably play chess some form of chests
try and stay away from checkers
anyway yeah thanks again to everyone
who's tuning in watching from all
corners of the world probably I'm gonna
hold off on at least f6 like the these
these f-pawn news have not been serving
me well at least in some games some
games they have I guess commute the bit
sounds like I do that that's a good
recommendation or how do I do that so I
could I could just turn off the work box
okay okay I think I did it
people are still welcome to cheer but it
should just it should be more quiet now
Ben says your play is attractive I'll
take that as a compliment hey it's bits
from Hari Krishna and a son yeah so okay
so that worked like it still shows up on
stream but it doesn't doesn't have any
distractions thanks for subbing
audacious audacious anthrax now this is
gonna be a really close finish if if
it's tied after the bullet then we play
we play one puzzle battle to determine
the champion if it gets to that that
will be insane but I'll see ya the forum
in the Chad you want some explanation by
an iPod yeah King F I think I'm just
lost here King f8 still work here like
everything's tied down it's so hard to
like stop the C pawn what are the odds I
don't know
Ben's ahead by one game so I have some
coming back to do
alright Ben's ready let's let's play
chess one minute okay
let's hide the chats okay should be
White's play what's funny for a sent
challenge sent
let's take you just want to hold onto
the pawn
yeah preventing b5
wants to play a three that's hard to
stop
so just letter the storm
to be very careful here
No well the game that was a crazy Wow
oh and he made of me with 0.6 seconds
that's so sad
no I simply came after you like or kingi
one good game then okay the game anymore
hmm very tricky
repeats even though always repeats
not that time okay 3d flag that's the
first like really dirty flag but let's
bullet what to do
okay this is full domination oh I hung a
thing though but it should be okay okay
Wow before it will save me okay it's
time was that in half eight and a half
that was Game three so seven more I need
to keep a tally but okay Kling b3 b4
been this line in d2 new
trista keep all the tension and now
before I made on d1 this is looking
Pleasant but still tricky from g1 Bishop
c5 actually Brooke to you when I can
take on f3 okay I'll go for taking on on
c3 we're taking on C 2 F 6 is hanging
mm-hmm let's go for this Wow okay man
I'm so nerve-racking um I was getting
four games are there total eight plus
six plus ten is twenty four okay so I'm
up let's just focus on chess this is
nice opening prep oh this I think II
fibers way to go to this movie that's
just a
and play simple chests go for d4 control
hopefully a five if I get the chance
hey Queenie one to h4 it before it's
getting complicated let's be five can
take and vision d4 I'll bow test gambit
do I decline the boat Eze let's accept
the boat s ah I can't move they're
attacking the salmon ooh oh that was a
really good move there goes all my
pieces how hot so close to mate so close
itself still needy please take it take
it take it take a ticket uh-huh you have
a free pawn mmm okay so it's tied nine
and a half nine 1/2 that's 19 so five
more games okay oh it's gonna be that's
gonna be close I like this line at least
hmm 27 save us more
everything that he's thinking that's
good I'm threatening made in three
when the bishop
my fish is still hanging you can take
backwards okay I have to do the math
that's okay so four more games or more
games let's go I'm gonna play a new
opening max game Queen h3 is tricky just
see to some meeting ideas one play night
94 and then maybe g4 rookie three a
queen sent me now I don't know the wins
it's close
oh wow Wow if that's what the match
comes down to well sorry sorry for the
dirty flag that was so dirty man okay so
but what's the score
it's I can't do math Oh
I was 21 games I was 21 so three more
I had my two they just transcoded into
something I'm some French it's not what
I like in d5 maybe when he finds my
smooth play each six happy to trade they
see fine
let's play this out yes King Power g5
left 43 is a plan
take care yeah and on g4 important move
should be winning let's be careful
where's my mates okay there we go
I didn't I was about to steal meat but
okay good thing I I had time I think
today like which the win I think I
clinched the win with that but I think
we played [ __ ] more let's go
oh so Bishop Bishop d2 is a move and
then efore 50 45 okay this is a very
pleasant position that's for wow it's
like a penis even though my phones are
frowning I can take yeah let's go for
quickest mmm
little bit confusing but it's kind of
working
no no each five you tried takes yeah
let's go for this
if King takes I didn't quit each five um
it's a good move I don't know what to do
here
just Bishop h5 and Queen G for incoming
that's a good room that's still really
complicated
I'm just about sevens cute and so crazy
what's going on here
okay I'm winning I should just be
winning this
I got pins I got skewered oh I tried I
tried
so we play it we play one more game I
believe one word rematch
so I've clinched I finished the win
let's go thanks Chad I see you chats oh
that was a crazy game though let's play
this move oh he's gonna play his his
yearís off I'll have to remember I
prepared this last night yeah none of
six and then takes he played Rufus
doofus in the slam that's some point on
chess talk on Queen d7 nice smooth and
then Bishop e7 I think and Bishop g5 and
then takes and Queen takes this is all
Rufus to this preparation there's a d7
and I think he played Queen h5 one game
this is a new move let's move
okay I was really prepared in the
opening but I'm still down on it's fine
g6 57 it's plenty real it's maybe six
now this pawn he's playing like alpha
zero but without the Alpha but kind of
each six is coming
maybe this move oh it's a skewer Queen
b1 always play Queen b1 wait I don't
want to trade rooks oh no g5 let's go
I'm gonna pawn don't fork me I don't
think there's a fork though I'm not
really threatening to take either this
move a pawn storm time points for him on
both sides so I don't know what else to
do Oh
g4 no meat is a threat what's up Mitra
oh the ID boat has ganda ah that's gonna
get draw dirty flag
good game ban man what a messy game I
don't I thought I was down on time I
don't know how it is up on time well
that's I guess a fitting end to this
match I wanted to think of that I feel
like it was a close match and then the
bullet was just a mess it could have
gone either way
boat s Canada followed by dirty flag
that was very fitting engine I was happy
to get this opening though my
assignments last night it's the best the
best line for black it feels weird but
Queen here
yeah nice match man thanks so much
oh man yeah that was a lot of Hobbit
chests a lot of dirty names to have to
like to analyze some of those games
the final score you can see the score
here I don't know how clear it was to
some people but ten and a half to
thirteen and a half then says next time
I'll find a British opponent probably
referring to Simon Williams
so I'm actually playing Simon Williams
in a match in a couple days in choker so
this was this was good preparation if
you like Ben and Simon have very similar
styles but they're almost the same
person with different accents